[Music]  check out this footage that we just  found this morning that was cut from the  Rankin ambass 64 classic Rudolph the  red-nosed reindeer no it's all settled  we eat tomorrow together but the  abominable will see my nose and get us  home I've got to go home  nonsense it's all for one and one for  all speaking of which who's up for a  three-way of course I wouldn't mind her  me you don't mind Rudolph red nose not  if you don't mind me being a dentist are  you kidding I love roleplay so what do  you say guys  [Applause]  [Music]  I think they did the right thing cutting  that scene yeah I think so  that house also seems small for that  does seem very small